Here the solutions for x are 4 plus or minus 2i times root 5. Fantastic work if
you found those solutions. This one wasn't so simple. First we subtract 36 from
both sides, to get this equation. Next, we complete the square by adding b over
2 squared to both sides. The b value is negative 8. So, that makes b over 2,
negative 4. We square this number to get 16. Adding 16 to both sides of the
equation, we get x minus 4 squared, this is our perfect square and negative 20
on the right. We take the square root of both sides of the equation, to get x
minus 4 equals plus or minus the square root of negative 20. Then, we add 4 to
both sides of the equation to get our solutions for x. We do need to do one
more step. We need to simplify. The square root of negative 20 is going to be
an imaginary number, since the radicand is negative. We can split up the square
root of negative 20 into these three square roots. The square root of negative
1 is i, the square root of 4 is 2. And we can't take the square root of 5, so
we leave it underneath the radical. These are our simplified solutions